Earlier on, we talked about how many gallons of cleaning solution Grant should
buy depending on how many orders he received from customers. Initially, Grant
had thought that he wanted to keep ten extra gallons of cleaning solution on
hand at all times, but he's changed his mind a little bit. He's gotten a ton of
orders, more than he was expecting. So, he's decided to adjust his surplus from
10 gallons to 20 gallons. What equation do we need now to describe how many
gallons of cleaning solution Grant should buy, depending on many orders he's
received? To be super clear, I've written down what each of our variables in the
original equation stood for. Also, the surplus of cleaning solution is the only
thing that Grant wants to change. He's not going to change the number of gallons
that he buys per expected order.